alright guys bangbang super-excited have
Alex here thanks for doing this man
thank you for having me pop I'm excited
to be on I've listened to a bunch of
your interviews and they're terrific and
glad to be in the hot seat for sure well
the big news obviously as you recently
left your job and have struck out on
your own to to go build a dominant
one-man media company for now so we'll
get to that in a second but for those
that don't know you maybe let's start
with with your background and kind of
how we got to you writing about large
technology companies yes so I came out
of school I studied industrial neighbor
relations came out in the middle of the
recession in 2009 didn't have a job sat
on my parents couch and was like what do
I do
so it was a moment where the internet
was starting to rise as an impactful
marketing platform and I took a
marketing job and I went in house as a
media buyer at New York City's Economic
Development Corporation and came in they
were doing a lot of print advertising
and I was like we can reach the same
readers for less money on the internet
and we can target them better and we
don't only have to buy on publications
we can buy on Google AdWords we can use
Facebook we could use LinkedIn and they
said really and I said oh yeah this is
all possible and so I just made it a
point to really learn how to spend money
best on the internet to reach audiences
and it was amazing just to see their
willingness like as a government agency
they don't move really fast but I had a
ten thousand dollar budget for each
campaign and it was amazing to see their
willingness to let me kind of spray it
around and see what the results are by
doing that you know I started to learn
the inner workings of how online
advertising works then I was in New York
for a while you know at this agency and
Bloomberg was the mayor at the time kept
talking about how important tech was to
the future of the city and at a certain
point I was like I'm done hearing him
talk about it I want to go do it
and I was like just get me to a tech
company any tech company and so I signed
on as a lead development representative
at an ad tech company that sold order
management software to publishers it's
about the most boring type of tech
company you could possibly be at maybe
like a nicob of an ERP system but not
too much further than that
and by doing that I learned the inner
workings of you know I had been buying
advertising through the internet now I
started to learn a little bit more about
the plumbing and at a certain point I
was like do I want to you know keep
trying to sell this software which was
all Direct sold we were moving automated
as the as an industry and so I said I
can keep trying to sell this stuff or I
could start to go to write about where
the energy was going
I chose the second path one to
Advertising Age started writing about
tech as a journalist was my first
full-time staff job and then you know
change you've been a part of write I saw
all the money moving from independent ad
tech out to Silicon Valley and all of a
sudden it wasn't like the tube moguls
and the Yumi's that were the power
players in the industry it was Facebook
and Google and Twitter and snapchat and
I said I could stay in New York and you
know write obituaries or I could move to
Silicon Valley and started to figure out
how these companies work and I decided
to make the move to Silicon Valley and
that's been the challenge since I've
been here and so I think part of what's
so fascinating about the work that
you've had is there's multiple kind of
levels or depths to it right so one is
just hey where's these industries going
how do these platforms work but also
then there's tens of thousands of people
that work at these companies now right
and so there's this kind of entire human
layer on top of it maybe talk a little
bit about some of the stories that you
wrote about in the process that goes
into really how you built your
reputation covering those large
technology companies right so I showed
up here I showed up in here in San
Francisco and May 2015
so almost exactly five years ago and I
had been this ad Trade reporter and so I
said let me make it a point to
try to cover everything I possibly can
sake my teeth into these companies in
every direction possible to see where it
leads me and it's interesting like you
cover an ad tech company like it's
pretty simple you have the cell side you
have the buy side you have some data
layered in between that's what you're
dealing with but when you come when you
cover a company like Facebook you're
dealing with you're not only the
advertising side but you're dealing with
politics entertainment how society works
you're looking at AI and and media you
know and so bye-bye I decided to go
pretty wide in the beginning and just
cover whatever I could and then I
started zeroing in on the things that I
thought were interesting and so to me
like the idea was to stop covering the
symptoms as much as to cover the
physiology look at the product decisions
look at the culture of these companies
and by deeply understanding and and
conveying the repercussions and the
results that these systems produce
people could better understand exactly
what's going on inside the company so
instead of for instance saying how could
Facebook not apply a label to Trump's
tweet or how did Twitter apply a label
to Trump's tweet you know for me the
more interesting thing is looking at why
do these platforms you know from an
elemental level start to incentivize the
type of posts where you end up having a
world leader who could end up putting
stuff out there that merits the label or
even that discussion like ad type of
stuff in my opinion doesn't happen by
accident and I wanted to learn you know
a why why do these companies products
spit out the type of communication that
they do and then be you know the thing
that motivated the book was it was kind
of astonishing to me that as these
companies got bigger they actually grew
stronger you know word used to companies
getting big and getting bureaucratic and
starting to you know batten down the
hatches and protect an asset and milk
that asset until there's nothing left
and then they become Xerox but these
companies are doing something very
differently they just become stronger as
they get bigger and I knew there was a
cultural story behind that and I just
wanted to find some way to go out and
tell it
and luckily you know I got the chance
with the book got into the book maybe
talk a little bit about kind of just
some of the takeaways there cuz what's
fascinating to me is we've seen a number
of books now written about individual
companies right and people spend months
if not you know more than a year really
going deep on one single company in
trying to just understand what's
happening to be able to write in depth a
full-length book you did that for
multiple companies right and so there's
this element of almost it's a more
difficult challenge when you're trying
to cover so many different businesses so
what are some of those takeaways that
that you had from writing the book yeah
and I think this is the first book that
Amazon Facebook Google and Microsoft
have all participated in together so
those are typical typically rivals and
they came together on this one so I
would say that that what motivated my
book is a different question right most
of the books that are out about these
technology companies are what did you do
what are you going to do for me the
question was how do you do what you do
and that's when you start to get into
things that you see you know instead of
telling a history you start to talk a
little bit more and it's kind of nerdy
but about process and technology and
culture and leadership that's enabled
them to be successful and the more I dug
into it the more I saw there were some
real parallels in the way these
companies operate one of the things that
they all do is that they have this view
of work and you might have seen this you
know in your various steps but they view
work as you're either gonna be spending
your time creating something new or
you're gonna be spending your time
supporting something that exists and
what they've done is minimize the time
people spent supporting what exists
using various forms of technology AI
automation collaboration tools to make
room for them to create something new
and that's kind of my idea with the
title which is always day one the idea
is that they're always reinventing
themselves it's as if their first day
with little regard for what came before
end and they do this by making much more
time for people to come up with new
ideas and bring them
life and then the second half of that is
they've built systems that once somebody
has an idea you know they're able to get
it to a decision-maker with incredible
speed
so at Facebook you probably saw if you
have an idea you could bring it right to
Zuck or maybe somebody who's gonna tell
Huck about it and it's a bull company
you tell your boss when you have an idea
and then your boss laughs at you and
then maybe they'll bring it to their
boss and their boss will laugh and
they'll bring it to their boss and if
anybody along the chain says no your
idea is gone and it start up across the
street who's now operating with the
lowest start-up costs in history who's
now operating with the fastest time to
create a company in history can go
create that idea while it's making its
way through the useless middle
management who are all laughing at you
and so the tech giants are done a really
good job of giving people the permission
to come up with ideas which is important
and then making sure that those ideas
have a way to get to decision-makers and
don't get caught up in that corporate
muck yeah I'll leave you take a step
further I actually tell people that one
of the things that was the most
surprising to me at Facebook is I would
see people come up with these ideas and
they would go to kind of somebody who
would have brought it to Jacques and the
response was not a I like that idea I
don't like that idea it was something to
the effect of like well if you're an
engineer like one that you prototype it
or if you're not an engineer like what
are you go try to find somebody who will
prototype it with you and then let's
talk about does this work does it not
want something to actually build right
kind this idea of like code win wins
arguments and to your point like it's
just all about speed right this and the
speed really leads to that innovation
which is uh which is pretty interesting
any kind of funny stories from the
process of writing the book and anything
that didn't make it into the book that
uh that you just found either funny or
or you think people would enjoy hearing
about yeah definitely a couple of fun
suck stories if you're up for them first
is so I knew Zuckerberg use a snapchat
and I kind of wanted to get him into
this position where he admitted it to me
and so I'm telling him you know we're
talking about stories and I have an idea
of how stories came to be you know again
as part of the feedback culture
telling him that you need to do this or
else your products are gonna die and I
knew that he was using snapchat and he
alluded to like you know watching
stories and I was like so you did it on
snapchat and he goes well and Instagram
I was like but you use snapchat and he
goes yep but I use all of our
competitors products and then he said um
he said he was when Facebook was
starting to experiment into the dating
app scene he had to try them out so he
got onto the dating apps with his own
picture he started experimenting with
them and he said he was on this one app
where you match with a new person every
day
and he thought it was a cool looking app
so he showed it to his wife Priscilla he
goes hey Priscilla check it out you know
here's this dating app that's pretty
interesting and she looked at the person
on screen and was scheduled to have
dinner with her the next night so anyway
it it's kind of one of those stories
where I'm like okay I'm sitting here
next to Zuckerberg and he's telling me
he's using dating app to meet as wide as
friends that's interesting
yeah I mean and look I think part of
that is like it's funny right and and
you know one of those are great stories
but - is it also shows the level of
maybe obsessions the wrong word but but
just really wanting to understand how
technology works what are other people
doing what should we be doing right and
being critical of products and I've said
over and over again you know mark was
probably one of the only people I've
ever met that could sit in a room and
talk about high-level strategy of an
entire division within a you know
multinational corporation and then
literally during the demo zoom in and
pick up you know why is that pixel off
right and just the ability to kind of go
up and down and and one time somebody
said to me who'd been to coming a long
time they said look you got to remember
that mark has more context than anybody
else who works here he's working on it
longer than everybody so he has the
story behind everything one of these
products he's seen them all get develop
and all this and if you kind of go
across all the major tech companies
that is one thing that remains constant
is most of them are still run by their
founders or the founders are still in
some sort of influential position which
I'm assuming that you kind of saw is one
of those patterns across the companies
right totally and I think that like
you're right the way that he's using
these apps shows a willingness to
believe in a product outside of Facebook
right but the problem that companies get
into is they believe that their software
is the best therefore they'll never even
try another person's software and like
to me was surprising that Zuckerberg is
using snapchat and dating apps but like
looking back of course he is like Amazon
has an interesting leadership principle
called invent and simplify and the idea
is you know you invent and then you
build systems to make sure you're not
spending too much time supporting that
existing product but they say explicitly
you know we don't have this dedication
to building to using stuff only invented
here if something was invented elsewhere
we'll use it and we're going with
best-of-breed you contrast that with
Microsoft when Steve Ballmer was running
Microsoft you couldn't bring an Apple
product into the campus you know Steve
Ballmer once pretended to throw an
iPhone in a meeting with people so
people sort of knew if I'm working on a
Mac even from developing for Mac users
I'm gonna get a dirty look if I'm
working on on this computer and Apple
can and sorry Microsoft canvas and I
think it sort of shows when you have a
willingness and an appreciation to ideas
from anywhere when you have a
willingness to admit that other
companies are developing good software
and you want to learn why they've done
well then you're gonna be in good shape
but when you want to sort of you know
again look and protect your asset and
think that that's the only thing that
matters in the world and that all your
competitors don't have a chance in the
world that arrogance ends up leading to
bad business outcomes for sure and since
you are the the go-to expert on these
big tech companies what's your
assessment of kind of their role in the
world right now obviously there's
everything from the coronavirus to the
economic crisis to now we've got kind of
social unrest in the United States and
in this debate over do you
you know label too
eat suppose do you not and kind of what
it what are is a platforms role like how
do you see the major tech companies
playing their role in society given that
again it's not just on one issue like
they pretty much touch everything at
this point I mean kind of evaluate that
role yeah III think they play important
roles are they the only actors in this
world no like do we when we talk about
Facebook's impact in the u.s. we have to
talk about Fox News and MSNBC and CNN we
talk about Twitter's impact in the world
we also have to talk about the way the
president uses it not just the product
so these are but they're all self
reinforcing systems and then we know
they have they're definitely changing
the way people in society see
information I mean the anti-vaccine you
know III don't think this is surprising
which is sad but the anti-vaccine
Facebook are growing at double the rate
that they were a year ago and so what's
gonna happen when we have a corona virus
vaccine and you know people you know buy
it by the tens of thousands refused to
take it because their minds been
poisoned inside these groups then you
get into you know pretty tricky
territory so I do think they're
definitely changing the way people think
I mean that was appealing to me you know
when I started going after this beat as
I would realize that these companies
have a pretty important role to play in
the way that information gets to people
now when I was I was coming from the ad
world I was mostly interested in what
publications they were going to support
but it turns out that they played you
know they've you know not surprisingly
played a role everywhere and like my
only thought on this is they got to slow
it down a little bit like they're too
fast and the share button and the
retweet button just enable like quick
unthinking dissemination of bad
information and if those buttons even
had like you know you have to wait ten
seconds before you hit them or you have
to click the link before you retweet the
story I think we would be living in a
better society
yeah and it's interesting because now
what we're starting to see is kind of
like divergence
in maybe not ideology but like action
right so the obvious one and maybe we
just talk directly about it is the
president's tweets where Twitter has
decided to go ahead and put a label over
those tweets
I think they've now extended that to
other government accounts that are
tweeting similar things are the same
things they've also gone and done to
other politicians Facebook instead has
taken the position that for the most
part they're going to be a kind of free
open platform they don't want to make
decisions on labeling things and not
labeling them they're obviously under
heat for that kind of walk me through a
little bit like your understanding based
on duck and Jack's specifically you know
those decisions are coming from the top
this isn't a policy person making it
like at the end of the day they are
maybe not betting their companies but
definitely stepping into a very
controversial situation so the CEOs
themselves are making these decisions
yeah and one of the things that's really
disappointed me in this whole situation
is that the employees protesting and the
media have only focused on the labels
and I'd love for them to focus on what
is going on inside your gear platforms
that are making them turn into what if
some people have really accurately
referred to as anger videogames and
we're like the points are retweets and
the points are shares and the points are
reached and why is the most incendiary
content from the most fringe actors
being amplified this way on these
platforms
I mean they've created status games so
people who have mainstream status are
not actually going in and playing in
them which means the fringe occupies all
of the room and then since the fringe is
making all this content for these for
these platforms they're just getting
amplified like crazy with the retweet
and share button so then we get into the
situation where the media sees like the
fur and say you know be pretty
successful and then say we need to you
know take this stuff down and that just
gives them fuel and say see this is you
know
we've been here all along and the
mainstream it has kept us down and they
don't want us to be successful but of
course that's not the case they've just
been been successful by nature of the
fact that they've rode these the systems
themselves and become pretty popular you
know on the platforms and in the world
because of it so I'd like to see that
fixed and I'd like to see more
discussion about that because until we
really get into that discussion you know
we're we're kind of talking about window
dressing now we you know that you know
as far as the labels go I don't really
think they're gonna make a difference
like Twitter put the label on Trump's
tweet and the rioting didn't stop so you
know they fact-check his his tweet about
mail-in ballots but I don't think that's
what's gonna make him stop trying to you
know start to cast aspersions on the
validity of this next election
you know he's behind in the polls why do
you think he's doing this so ultimately
I think that that Jack has been more
willing to act then mark and so this
sort of ends up following that that type
of pattern but I know I know this is
sort of unsatisfying but I think that
neither of them are in the right until
they start to examine the fundamentals
of what their platforms are doing and
start to fix them yeah and it's really
interesting because I do think that most
people are focused on this idea of like
are the platform's becoming publishers
and they think of it in this like
editorial perspective but it's always
about did they put the label or did they
not did they censor or did they not and
coming from somebody who who's worked on
these systems and understands you know
some of the the complexity of them like
there's a lot more to and it's very
nuanced right it could literally just be
payouts posted something and he gets
less reach because of a word he used
right or the the easy example I always
tell people is on Facebook for example
if you see a post and everyone starts
writing congratulations in the comments
it explodes right because obviously
everyone's writing congratulations it
must be this like super engaging
awesome thing for this person and
everyone then gets this dopamine hit and
it's like this self-fulfilling you know
cycle but that's kind of an editorial
decision as well right like what goes
rhythm exactly that's exactly it like
they are they've been editors they are
editors they will be editors and whether
they put a label on a tweet or send you
to a fact check what's happening
underneath is playing a far greater role
then when you see them act with a
quote-unquote heavy hand like let's look
at the systems and let's look at the
belly of the beast you know versus its
haircut all right so most people who
listen to this will agree in some form
or fashion that the platform's have a
hard time claiming hey we're the phone
company right the phone company the
analogy they're just hey look they don't
listen to they're not supposed to listen
to the calls right and definitely don't
ya they don't say hey I'm trying to call
Alex but because we're gonna talk
politics like I'm not gonna connect the
call right or I'm gonna cut you short at
five minutes rather than give you 30
minutes because we're gonna talk about
something in the conversation so it's a
look it's not quite an apples to apples
comparison but what is the solution
right and so when you talk about like
examining the actual kind of belly of
the beast like they let's say that they
say okay you know what we have this
problem we're gonna go ahead and be very
introspective we're gonna take this
seriously like what do you think is the
the direction that they can go or that
like finish line if you will where they
end up creating solutions yep so I don't
want to be one of those people who say
they must do something because as you
know unless we test something we don't
really know what the outcome is gonna be
but I do know what I want to test so I
want to test and see what the outcome is
if three things on the share button one
is if you remove share and retweet
completely two is if you put a ten or
fifteen second timer you know on that
retweet so you have to wait 15 seconds
after you've seen it before you can hit
it and three is if you have to click the
link before before you can hit that
button and we know research shows if you
don't have
you're much more likely to share fake
and sensationalized news I would say
probably outrage as well right if we put
that pause in artificially I am really
curious to see what the platforms will
find out and my guess is that it will
create a much better environment inside
the other thing is status right so
here's the other thing I want to test
I'd love to test what these platforms
look like without follower counts and
without retweet and light counts now
look these are gonna have you know
potentially some negative effects right
because we might not be able to tell
someone who's pretty influential from a
bot so it will put their you know
opinion down you're kind of on the same
plane which has been an issue so I'm not
sure this is an issue but I'd like to
actually see what it looks like and then
maybe you could just do tears right
because think about it
Twitter counts up every single follower
that you have you can see it and and you
know anybody on Twitter knows that
that's freaking addicting and hard not
to check what a twitter did it here you
know your 500 plus your 1000 plus your
2000 plus 3000 you know then all of a
sudden you know it becomes less of a
saddest game and more of a signal in
terms of audience and I think that like
if we end up testing things of this
nature on you know you know along the
lines of what I'm suggesting we will end
up getting to a more civil place because
again this this status game with quick
fur ality to me seems unwinnable for
everyone I mean it's pretty good for
engagement it keeps people checking
these things more than they should but
if we're thinking about the way that
society is impacted by these platforms
these are some of the fixes I'd like to
see and I guess one of the things and
I'm kind of thinking out loud here but
really if you think about following
people without the follower accounts
email list had basically done that right
so like hey I subscribe to Sunday list a
lot of times I don't know how many
subscribers they have I may have a good
sense of it's big where it's not but but
really unless they tell me I've got zero
clue
I'm just subscribing for that
that content which is kind of it sounds
directionally one of the things that
those tests would try to see it is that
make the platform quote unquote better
based on the metrics that you're using
yeah Eugene way it has this great post
about he calls its status as a service
and talks about how humans are status
hungry monkeys and we're you use these
platforms as the incentives teach us to
and again like you know it's not like
this is the first time society is
fraying like we had a Holocaust before
Twitter and Facebook so I don't think
they're the cause of all evil but I do
think that the public discourse that we
have is important and it does lead to
you know a lot of outcomes in real life
and so if we can find ways to improve it
first to say oh this is just the way it
is it's just gonna be better for all of
us and we can maybe you know I know it's
we're not in a time where we can start
talking about social media with this
utopian view that it was talked about in
the beginning but I don't think the
promis'd is is gone yet I think we can
get to a better place with social media
just not the type of social media we
have today yeah and the other thing I
always you know remind people of and I'm
biased look I worked at some of these
companies right it's just like they've
had a net positive impact on society in
my opinion in the sense of you know how
many people are now connected and all
stuff now there's bad things that came
with it I think they would be the first
ones to admit that you know there's
challenges and they've got to try to
solve them but but I think that these
are really important conversations and
really what we're asking every large
tech company to do is do the impossible
right give us all the benefits without
any of the downsides but but it's some
of the downsides are definitely worth
focusing on and addressing in the short
term what's going on with with Google
and Amazon and some of the like
non-social media large tech companies in
your opinion yeah so Google is in the
middle so in the book I talked a little
bit about how Google people think Google
is this company that figured out how to
do search and just wrote it to a multi
you know hundred billions of dollars of
valuation and that was it
but Google is this company that's really
gone through so many different
transformations in its history it
started out as a website you would
access on Microsoft's browser Internet
Explorer then it really became a browser
extension on Internet Explorer I don't
know if you know many people remember
but the primary way that people used to
access Google was through Google toolbar
which is an extension you would install
on to Internet Explorer and it would
like show up in the browsers you know
Chrome every Chrome is everything that's
not part of the browsing window and you
would type your searches in and it would
show up in the browser actually more
than 60% of Google search went through
toolbar at a certain time so Google was
an extension then the Google team saw
led by sundar pichai who is now the CEO
of alphabet they saw that Microsoft was
starting to mess with them a little bit
with that toolbar as you might imagine
Microsoft was like we're delivering
billions of dollars to Valley a value to
Google and we all the browser's so why
we continue to do this and so Google
realized that the longer it depended on
Microsoft which was then working on live
search which would become Bing it was
going to be dead and that's when it
really had to build its own browser and
it's funny I remember seeing ads for
Chrome and being like why is Google
building a browser why is the search
engine so intent on the browser but
Chrome saved the company and without
building its own successful browser
where you can type your searches in the
address bar you know we might be begging
today like that might be the verb and so
that that's obviously chrome worked out
really well for them so Google's safe
but then we move from desktop to mobile
all of a sudden they need to reinvent
again and they do that using Android
which they acquire and then build up and
then you know we start we start getting
into this mobile world all of a sudden
voice computing happens and what you do
with Google is you ask it questions you
know what time is is this gonna happen
at you know where did this take place
and people start asking the you know
Amazon echo these questions this is
Google's bread and butter so Google
needs to reinvent again and that's where
it started developing the Google
assistance sundar brings the whole
company together
and he puts this big slide up in front
of it in front of the company and it's
all Google's products and there's like
this squiggly line and it points to
assistant and so the number one thing
that we're doing in this company is
turning what we have into one cohesive
assistant the Google assistant and I
think that like this is gonna be
Google's future as whether it can make
that assistant overtake you know the
echo I can't stay here fleming pause
butte it so i overtake alexa or you know
it can't lose that and and if google if
the google assistant is good then all of
a sudden it propels all the Google
products you use it propels Android and
it propels the Google home which is
still second to the echo but if you look
at the order
you know the echo is it has the lead
then you got Google then there's like an
other category and some are deep inside
that other category which has very few
units sold as Apple's home pod so Apple
is totally letting this revolution slip
by it in terms of Amazon you know Amazon
just like this invention factory its
culture you know I talked a little bit
about you know working on ideas versus
working on execution and its culture has
you know baked in and like incredible
technology that allow its employees to
focus on invention and that's why
Amazon's been able to go from you know a
online bookseller to a massive first
party marketplace a third party
marketplace logistics and fulfillment
operation a cloud services platform a
voice computing platform a hardware
manufacturer and a grocer and an academy
award-winning movie studio is because
the company knows how to operate its
processes baked in and we're starting to
see some of the fruits of you know its
most ambitious AI program called hands
off the wheel and I go into that in
depth in the book hands off the wheel is
a wave that Amazon used machine learning
to automate a good amount of tasks in
its retail organization so its retail
employees were on the phone with like
brands like tide and saying we need this
many detergent units and this many
fulfillment centers you know at this
time
this price and Amazon looked at itself
it was like we got two decades worth of
retail purchase data why are we having
people do this we can just have software
and then slowly but surely over the last
few years they've worked to automate all
these tasks so if you're tied right now
a machine sends you the purchase order
you get an email right you go and
negotiate with a portal the pricing and
promotions are all done with technology
not people used to be a very big
organization inside Amazon and by
freeing those people up the company's
really been able to invent you know
who's next new products my favorite
story is one of this guy tell Kumar who
ran pricing and promotions in the retail
organization he goes and spends like a
year and a half under Bezos taking
meetings that he that Bezos was taking
as a second achill advisor by the time
he's done pricing and promotions is
totally automated so we can't go back to
this division so he gets together with a
bunch of people from Amazon's retail
organization that are feeling this place
to need to do something new and they say
why don't we use technology to solve the
most annoying part of shopping in real
life which is checkout and that is the
team that developed Amazon Go which you
can just walk in and take something out
and then it charges you you know there's
no scanning you skin and once with a QR
code grab what you want and then walk
out it feels like stealing probably the
future of brick-and-mortar retail period
I think that these systems we're gonna
see in supermarkets all over the place
and and in stores and and I think that
Amazon's really hit on something with
this and it all happened because they
were able to use technology to change
the way they work and make room for more
invention and have the process to invent
so I think that company is you know
really good shape from a business
standpoint the only caveat I'll make
what the Amazon is the company needs
more empathy you can tell by the way
that they've engaged in this coronavirus
moment that they they've fired their
whistleblowers they've tried to run a
nasty PR campaign targeting somebody in
their fulfillment center that spoke up
saying he was inarticulate and they
wanted to make him the face of you know
worker resistance then honestly like
it's much easier to
to treat your workers well then to go
through all this effort and a PR
campaign to try to make somebody look
bad and I think at a certain point
Amazon needs to realize that because you
know connect you know consumers might
one day actually say I want to go to a
company that's first priority is making
sure that the people I work for it it's
safe are safe and making sure that the
businesses that sell into it are
sustainable that's good for everyone and
if Amazon doesn't prioritize that it's
going to be in bad shape yeah that's a
fantastic overview it's fascinating how
the use of technology across these
companies this idea of not spending time
supporting things that have been built
and just constantly innovating
constantly inventing you know it's kind
of that that layer of commonality across
all of them in terms of also inventing
or building something you recently made
the jump to leave your job and go go it
alone maybe talk a little bit about what
you're doing and kind of what the
thought process was behind leaving and
starting big technology yes so I was at
BuzzFeed for five years as a senior
technology reporter in BuzzFeed years I
think that's 35 or so it's a long time
in a digital media company and I release
always day one in April and you know
what happened we released in the middle
of a pandemic which is you know if I
write a second book I'll make sure to
not release in a pandemic because it
adds an element of challenge to the hope
system that that isn't great and I
basically kind of looked at my what's
gonna happen to me in my life over the
next handful of years and said you know
I could stay here and you know stay in
this staff job hopefully and try to ride
out what's going on in this pandemic and
you know keep reporting on these
companies in the traditional news
ecosystem or I could just try to take my
future and my destiny in my own hands
and that means helping to get the word
out about the book in a way that I
wasn't beforehand because again like
full time reporter job it's pretty
demanding and I
I think that there are some lessons in
the book that are valuable to you know
anyone no matter what industry they're
in and and you know spent a long time
working on it and figured it was worth
that effort and then the other thing is
so you know I think that and you are you
know totally
you know you've been early and ahead of
this for a long time is that I I think
we're seeing the movement of reporters
people with perspective you know people
with something to say to do it without a
filter to do it with as a direct
relationship with readers and listeners
and you know I've been writing about
this for a while and seeing it take
place and I thought it was possible I
believed in and you know what people
like you are doing and said it's time
for me to give it a shot so along with
going and spent you know leaving and
spending more time you know getting the
word out about always day one I wanted
to start my own publication so I did I
went to sub stack I've had discussions
with the sub stack eyes for a while and
you know I I trust them I think it's a
good platform and a good place to start
out so I'm starting this new newsletter
called big technology on sub stack and
it's not entirely like I've been writing
a newsletter for BuzzFeed called the
tech giant update but again trying to do
that in between stories now I'm gonna
make the newsletter my main focus and
I'm sure like it you know you've done
this right you you know you know when
you send a newsletter and you have
people that reply and then you could
start having a conversation with them
that's so rewarding so much more
rewarding than putting it on a website
so I'm really looking forward to that
back and forth interaction with
subscribers and then you know I'm gonna
do podcast as well and you know if
people subscribe to the newsletter then
until you know be able to get a heads up
when the podcast comes out but to me you
know the best part of my day is spent
speaking with interesting people and
trying to figure out what their
worldview is like and you know I just
think that it would be pretty cool to be
able to release those conversations to
the world and so I'm right now
trying to find a partnership with a
media company I've had a couple of good
conversations so far we're like we would
do like a sort of an audience for
revenue yeah audience for content trade
and then a revenue split essentially
saying you know I I think I have a
pretty good idea of how to make this
content you you have an established
audience you know I want to start big
and so the idea would be to do this
partnership you know they help drive
listeners and I'll you know go out there
and make sure to to make great audio and
so I think by the end of June we'll have
something to announce on that front
that's awesome yeah one of the things
going back to the kind of the social
media conversation and the algorithms I
keep going back and forth on there's
definitely this value of rather than
write an article put it into a
publication on the web and then have
that distributed through social media
and hope that the algorithm gods are
kind and give you a big boost email is
still one of the best ways to deliver
content right you have that relationship
directly with the reader recently I've
had two separate people say yes but
don't forget that Google of all
companies could put you in the
promotions tab right and and there can
be a little bit of filtering there as
well and so how have you just thought
about you know there's a content
creation but then there's the delivery
and so it sounds like you're pursuing
still written and audio so kind of two
different channels there but but any
thoughts about just like what you can do
to continue to you know really cultivate
a relationship directly with the reader
or the listener and and kind of wean
yourself off the dependency on some of
these larger platforms mm-hmm yeah I
think it's a reality today like anyone
who says that email is total totally
filter free is probably kidding
themselves like you definitely are going
through a filter with email like you
mentioned Google's or you know
Microsoft's if you're sending they're
the one thing that I found really
amazing about email is though is just
that like when you go and inbox is a
pretty sacred space for people people
get mad if they see a bad email now
they're okay if they see
bad tweet so they're in even if it's in
the promotions tab so there's a lot of
trust coming in and you have to when I
think for like from my perspective when
I'm gonna send an email you know it's
gonna I make sure that it's gonna be
worth somebody opening it if they do
decide to make that click and then you
know people have controls right that you
can drag an email and I've done this
with plenty of newsletters that I like
I've seen it show up in my promotions
tab I can drag it into my main inbox and
say Google will say do you want this to
appear here from now on and I'll do that
but yeah ultimately we are at the mercy
of big technology company algorithms
whether we like it or not and I think
the thing that we can do is give
ourselves the best our best chance to be
able to cut through the noise and so if
you ask me would you rather send an
email or send a tweet an email is much
much better way to do it I mean I'll do
both but I I just think the two-way
communication on emails is so great and
there's something something else is nice
about it I don't know if you found this
if we're sending your email but the
privacy is cool where people feel that
comfortable to share thoughts they
wouldn't share like as a reply on
Twitter you know I got a reply on
Twitter you know typically you'll get
like you know you're a dumbass and
here's why I'll reply on email you might
actually get something civil and
something constructive and a way to
think about the issue in a different way
and and then more stories will come that
way so I'm pretty freakin excited to get
sending and yeah you know over the past
week I was going through some of the
replies to the tech giant update and
just like man like a lot of people were
like you know send these more often and
I was like yeah but I'm writing stories
full-time so to be able to combine that
is something I'm stoked for yeah I could
definitely vouch for the idea that the
feedback is much much more thoughtful
via email sometimes literally people
write back like paragraphs and
paragraphs I'm like what wow you really
care right like like you really were
listening and and thoughtful about this
so definitely agree there how do you
think that this affects right like going
from
working in a large publication where
when you reach out the sources or
anything like that
it's a BuzzFeed reporter is reaching out
to now it's alex is reaching out right
and you're gonna build the name of a
publication but on day one
you are better known than the
publication right now over time
hopefully that kind of flips but how do
you think that that affects that one the
stories that you can kind of get access
to to the relationship with sources and
maybe kind of talk through if you did
any analysis there or thinking as to
whether that would change the way that
you actually could cover some of this
stuff yeah it's going to be hard like I
don't think it's gonna be easy like you
have to in this world you have to earn
it
right people are gonna see big
technology many of them have never seen
a story from it I've never even seen my
intro post and so I'm gonna have to go
and earn trust and and make a mark by
you know producing big hard-hitting
stories and so like my goal I'm gonna
give it a couple of weeks before launch
because I have a couple I'm reporting
out but I want to come out guns blazing
and then like the other thing is that
like you know I kind of know what this
is like because I was one of the
original members and BuzzFeed Silicon
Valley bureau and we came on the scene
and you know BuzzFeed BuzzFeed had done
some tech content before but it wasn't
known to be a hard-hitting tech desk and
so we had to literally prove to the
world that we were capable of doing the
work that they should pay attention to
and that required a lot of hard work
that required you know getting on the
phone and you know sometimes sources are
just like okay but BuzzFeed you know or
they were like you know I'll speak to
anyone that's what it was one I loved oh
okay you're for BuzzFeed I'll speak to
anyone you know which was literally what
happened to me be like oh I thought this
was for ad age you know now people would
much rather speak to BuzzFeed than at
age I think and so yeah we had to
you can't we had to work hard we had to
punch hard and we couldn't go into it
with an ego or a narrative right I feel
like if you go in knowing knowing what
you're doing and then writing original
pieces not narrative driven pieces you
know you go in writing
people actually get value out of not
like the 10th version of the story that
everybody's written that's where you're
gonna make people want to start to speak
with you I think I mean I don't know
like to me the cool thing about starting
this on my own is if I get this right I
can keep it you know that's pretty mean
for sure
and I think part of the allure of going
out on your own right for for journals
that I've seen do this is hey look I got
to write the stories that I want to
write right and it's not to say that
they couldn't always do that but but
there's definitely editors and kind of
other things at play when you're writing
stories and so that's an attractive
component to it but what you lose is
those editors you lose some of the
support staff use some of the resources
so kind of have you thought about the
pros and cons of those large
organizations right you get some freedom
but you also lose some resources and
just kind of like how do you balance
that in your head and think about it as
you kind of start now yeah so I mean
I've done seven years as a full-time
reporter after starting out freelance
and I feel like if I were to do this
starting out I wouldn't know what I was
doing like I mean I started out you know
doing Forbes blogging when Forbes would
let lots of people you know go and use
its platform and that was like a good
learning moment for me and it was a way
for me to sort of make mistakes in real
time now like I feel like I have an idea
you know of what I'm doing and I feel
confident that I'll be able to find the
stories that are gonna cut through and
like you know what my newsletter
beforehand I think that watching the
type of stuff that I would write and how
it would resonate with people was like a
good chance for me to sort of give this
a give us a shot experiment a little bit
and see if it could be something more
broadly more broad you know you can't
you can't I feel like everyone could use
an editor like you can't replace the
value an editor brings so while I'm
excited to start assigning myself
stories I am gonna miss that second set
of eyes you know this isn't something
interesting the Ben Smith brought up in
one of his recent columns about
you know people going out and going
independent whether it's celebrities or
like you know you know people with
influential tech followings or like be
less journalists like myself you know
it's like the services that are the
services that are there for you like sub
stack may eventually start doing
something like you know once they get
enough people are they gonna have an
editor on call that you can just you
know call to and talk a little bit about
I could see that happening are they
gonna have health care okay that might
be more of a stretch but the editor
thing certainly certainly possible and
you know until that day like you know
when I have something that's pretty you
know controversial or you know I'm not
sure about
I'll just gut check it like I'm lucky to
have friends who are reporters who you
know I probably can't ask them every day
but every now and again I'm sure I can
say hey can you just take a look at this
before I hit the publish button and I
don't know if it's gonna be something
that will be smooth all the time like it
will definitely have hiccups in the way
that working in a established media
corporation you know didn't you know
wouldn't have as many of and you know my
approach to this is to admit that that's
gonna happen to ask my readers to trust
me to admit when I mess up because I
will and to learn and grow from it yeah
I look you already know this but I'd be
remiss if I didn't tell you the whole
key is the persistence of just doing it
in a very disciplined manner right hey
I'm gonna write every Monday write every
Monday and make the mistakes and stuff
but I think I've been writing on sub
stack for two years now actually as of
May and that's probably the most
defendable thing I've done is I just did
it everyday writing and a lot of other
people started out and then stopped at
some point how do you think about this
changing the content you write and what
I mean by that is when you're writing a
story at BuzzFeed it's less your opinion
and it's much more kind of reporting the
facts now you do have that trust of the
reader right they're subscribing to hear
from you you think that that
leads to more opinionated pieces do you
want to write more opinion like to talk
a little bit about how you kind of
balance the opinion component given that
now it's less hey I'm just reading this
on BuzzFeed and maybe I don't know or or
I haven't paid attention to who the
writer is till now no I'm specifically
getting this because I've chosen to get
content from Alex yeah I mean I think
the reporting will lead the way so
people are gonna hear the reporting
first and in my opinion second but I
think that there's definitely going to
be a more opinion and the stuff that I
write and I'm excited to do that
I don't think there should be in any
form of journalism well actually maybe
that's debatable but like every venue
you should have if you have an opinion
you should have the ability to write it
otherwise you know we're holding stuff
back from readers and well you know who
does that get what type of good does
that do I'm not into it
so yeah I think the readers of this
newsletter will hear what I think for
real
there might be surprised like you know
like I talked about narratives like
oftentimes coverage goes and narratives
you know people say what's the big story
and then they'll try to advance you know
and I'm just kind of skeptical of that a
lot of the time like people will not
hear you know after reading a story in
the New York Times in the Wall Street
Journal and BuzzFeed and fortune and in
Forbes they won't see my you know same
story they're gonna see a different
perspective from me so it's going to be
there'll be a lot of first-person
there'll be some opinion I mean my book
is like a good example and you know is
day one you'll see the reporting lead
you'll get I feel like a reader can kind
of get lost in the reporting and then
I'll bring it back and to like what I
saw and what I felt and yeah like I
think it'll be it'll be a two-way
conversation it will be me learning from
subscribers than learning from me and
who knows like it might go in different
interesting directions we could get
spiritual we can think about you know
things like meaning which i think is
important to think about
you think about tech and ultimately
we'll just I'll just let that two-way
discussion drive yeah it's really
interesting too because you keep
mentioning this to a discussion and it's
almost like what you actually end up
doing is you end up building a community
right and in that community is there to
kind of consume the content that you're
creating within the discussion
afterwards there's kind of intellectual
satisfaction to it but also to that's
what ultimately brings value as well and
so as part of that like how do you think
about monetizing all of this is this a
there's some for free and some that
people will pay is it an ad-supported
model like how do you kind of we're
talking about it as if you've been doing
it for years obviously you're just
starting but like like what does that
monetization look like you know as you
see it today yep so I have like three
main monetization goals one is I'll just
do the easy one first to sell another
book so to me that is the first thing
I'm gonna do is do my best to get always
day one out there as much as I can and
hopefully that gives me another
opportunity to write another book second
with the newsletter I'm going to go to a
model of a free article probably free
article a week and then maybe two or
three for subscribers only through the
week so it will be reader supported and
then third will be the podcast like I
mentioned I'm gonna try to build a big
audience on that and then just do
revenue share with a with a media
company I mean if you know with the
podcast in the newsletter like if the I
mean I'm kind of curious what you think
about this but like if the podcast does
really well or the newsletter does
really well then maybe I can you know
make the other one free like if the
newsletter crushes it you know probably
do like the podcast like ad-free or if
the podcast gets a big audience then I
can move and make the newsletter you
know free to everyone to me they they
all reinforce each other and I'm not you
know my goal isn't to get rich off of
this my goal is to sort of be
able to do this type of work that I love
to do and share you know what I know
about these companies and what I know
about the tech world you know without an
end date anywhere like support myself
independently and not be reliant on
somebody else to give me the permission
to do that I think you're thinking about
it the right way I mean that that's
what's so crazy about all this right and
you know I've obviously thought a lot
about it but I forget the the woman's
name who coined the term of the the
passion economy but basically this idea
then you know look you only need a
couple hundred people to pay for whether
it's reader or listener supported
content and most people could replace
their salary right with just a couple
hundred and and so what's I think really
interesting is when you see journalists
leaving to go start this you did a
pretty good job outlining like it's the
same body of work yeah there's some
tweaks and maybe with some less
resources whatever but like you're still
writing about the things that you were
writing about and want to write about
you're just choosing to monetize that
work in a different way and it involves
taking more risk right because if you're
unsuccessful in getting people to pay
for it then obviously you make less
money but you also have uncapped upside
and so it's very interesting to kind of
see you know some people are very
attracted that and some people say hey
look just pay my paycheck and you know I
don't want to ever think about
monetization in my life I just wanted to
do my work so it's kind of cool now that
the tools are in place for other people
who previously didn't have this you know
Avenue to pursue they have it now right
totally yeah and you know I've I've a
high risk tolerance and I've been you
know I mean started it out on the
business side as opposed to starting out
in journalism so I've seen the changes
in the media industry you know reported
on the changes in media and social media
and you know succeed or fail like this
will be a cool experience to kind of see
what it's all about once I get out there
I love that attitude before I finish up
I always asked two questions and then
you get to ask me one question to finish
what is the most important book that
you've ever read other than your own
um this is I love the book the forever
war by Dexter Filkins have you read it
tastic book yes I'm getting chills just
thinking about it because well net we're
never gonna have so so fruit for your
listeners who haven't read it it's a
book by this correspondent who'd been at
the New York Times and The New Yorker
covering the wars in Afghanistan and
Iraq and I don't think we're ever going
to have another book like this because
he was sort of the last war reporter to
write a book about what it was like to
embed with people who are fighting with
the US where they still needed the
filter there was no YouTube for the
Taliban to use when he was in
Afghanistan and so he got unbelievable
access and is able to tell this
fascinating first-person story about the
sort of repercussions of the u.s. action
in those two countries and I think that
yeah I don't know I just was blown away
by every single chapter that he that he
told and I think that um it's a good
read for anyone that's trying to figure
out sort of what actually happens when
the u.s. in goes in and invades because
too often were you know we are networks
won't really show us what's happening
there our newspapers won't won't cover
the full story they do a good job
getting the basic details but we don't
really see the extent and I think the
book does a really good job of that yeah
it's one of these books that not only
has great content kind of the access and
just information you can't get anywhere
else and then it's also very
well-written as well right a lot of
times you get one or the other this one
has both and that's I read that a while
ago but that's a fantastic yeah
suggestion second question is a more fun
one which is aliens believer or
non-believer Oh pop you got me on the
tough one here at the end I'm gonna just
say that if we had if if there
aliens out there I'll be shocked but not
surprised like okay well yeah because
math says there should be but we haven't
seen any any of them yet and I know
there's that theory that like you know
maybe most civilizations get to a
certain point and then they annihilate
themselves and right now that seems
fairly believable so it possible that
all the other aliens have annihilated
themselves at this point and we haven't
really made contact with them but I mean
we think about it
universe is big and you know the the
chance of another earth-like planet is
not out of the picture so you know if
they're here
oh yeah like remember when there was
that comment that comment that was gonna
came pretty close and I think I had
tweeted something you know you know
appreciate your interest in visiting but
we're going through some [ __ ] right now
maybe try another time that would sort
of be my message to the aliens like or
maybe they should come now because you
know might as well you know deal with
all the crap at one time that would be
the most on-brand 20/20 thing ever right
is like Oh aliens came to of course they
did exactly what do you think pop I
definitely think that the math suggests
that there's other life right I cheat
because I've asked this question out a
300 people were at every variation of
answer but I think the two big questions
are are you talking about life or
intelligent life so let's just say that
we're talking intelligent life okay math
would suggest it's out there somewhere
but then to and I forget who's the
person who originally said this to me as
part of their answer but they said yes
but then you have to cut it also by time
and what they basically we're saying is
like the odds from if you just look at
how vast the galaxy is is that there is
other intelligent life out there but
they could have been here a million
years ago right or they could you're a
million years from now and I said look
you know you're blowing my mind to the
point where like I feel you know but it
not only small insignificant and
also just really stupid right because
these are so complex yeah but but like
the math suggested and so from a
probability standpoint you know we it is
probably out there but we have but we
haven't identified it like that's the
other thing is right is how we have
already discovered them and just have it
set it yet I don't I don't go that far
have you seen the videos of the flying
saucers that are being captured by the
air force and are you buying and selling
on the idea that's extraterrestrial life
so I've seen them I don't know what to
think of them frankly and really what I
mean by that is there's two pieces to it
one is there's something there right
unless they're like literally it's a
optical illusion or something but but it
appears that something's there - is that
the part that actually makes the
argument around alien life or something
else the most believable to me is
actually the fact that there's multiple
reports of things that we can't explain
with physics today right so hey we've
got this understanding of science but
something that we saw we can explain
through what we're seeing look you know
there was plenty of things in science we
didn't understand a hundred years ago
that we now understand today because the
technology whatever
so doesn't mean that we can't figure it
out but just like that to me is probably
one of the more compelling arguments for
like why aliens would exist okay I got
one last question for you sorry I'm
taking over your interview but yeah I
realized part two topic of interest for
me all right so I'm sure you have
friends in the tech world who believe
that were in a simulation so how do you
react when you hear that 2020 anything's
possible no III think it's again it's a
probability thing right people way
smarter than me have done all the math
and could you know rattle it off
I don't know how probable it is what I
would say is when you start to go down
this path of like simulation aliens
whatever
I actually kind of come at it weird
because because what look from a life
experience standpoint right like I went
to Iraq right now I was at war like I
solve that kind of stuff and you just
get reminded like we're all gonna die
right and so like is it a simulation or
they're aliens like war all this chaos
whatever like we're all gonna die and
you and I are about the same age and you
just gotta start thinking like yeah I
think I've got like another 50 years or
so rather I think that's what the mask
would tell me is it you know
probability-wise but that could be not
happen and I could die tomorrow and so
it's just like let's just enjoy what we
have right let's go live our lives could
do the cool [ __ ] now because uh if we're
living in a simulation or anything else
like I almost don't want to know right
it's like let me believe I'm actually
doing the things that I want to do yeah
that's like the old question like if you
do today
you're gonna die what you want to know
ah oh thanks for sure where can we set
people to a one find the book and then
to to to sign up for for big technology
yes so if you google always day one or
Bing always day one or type it into
whatever weird search engine you use
you'll be able to find it everywhere
Amazon Barnes & Noble book bound the
whole deal Apple books if that's your
cup of tea
I haven't been banned on Apple books yet
so that's good and the newsletter is
just big technology sub stack calm
and yeah that thing will be firing up
any day now so I'd love to see you all
there awesome awesome man we'll link to
both of those in the in the description
as well and then appreciate doing this
you know best of luck as you go down
this path because I think it's a it's
pretty cool that that you're doing it
and I got no doubt that you're you're
gonna be pretty successful yeah thank
you pop I'm looking forward to
continuing to listen